All right welcome to another Zoom call just a reminder to search our blog and our on our website for questions that you may not want to wait until our Zoom call, plus remember to search our patient membership site.
You're not on the patient membership site, make sure you send me an email at info at cutters clinic.com or make sure you search.
Your email, your main email for the info at cutters clinic dot com email where you would have gotten a invite for you can search membership.
Maybe I'll find it that way too.
All right let's get to it first question.
I did forget to ask about heavy metals too.
So first I asked some questions.
My friend gave me about a TRS because she had amazing results with it so just so you know TRS is a liquid zeolite product that is a great binder and key later.
So zeolite is a great binder and a great key later.
So it can help pull out heavy metals.
I'm just wondering if it's okay because it works with negative ions and stuff I don't understand.
If it's not compatible with using the right probably a dumb question.
But I want to develop that color since it's safe. Yes it's safe.
It's fine it's not going to hurt the right.
Yep use that if that's what you think this would be the right thing for you.
Again when we put together a protocol for people if you want to use other things that's totally up to you as well.
This is not a my way or the highway thing so if you feel like God's leading you in that direction certainly go ahead and use that.
Does bio tip in shampoo or gummies help with decreasing hair loss.
Bio tip to take it or they could be good for your nails and your skin and your hair.
Within shampoo I know there's a lot of sales tactics of shampoo companies with things they're going to put a bio tip and in the shampoo I honestly I have no idea what how it works topically of your hair.
I've never researched that I am highly doubt that it does a whole lot.
Maybe it makes your hair thicker simply because it's attached to the hair follicles on the outside it makes the hair appear thicker.
Maybe that's good for some people but certainly you certainly don't absorb anything through your phone through your ship through the bio tip insurance that very well absorb so.
Or more so sales type so.
I spoke to Dr. Cutters about my high TSH TSH is thyroid stimulated whole record mode and low thyroid this afternoon.
Let me do it to read and see that cruciferous and vegetables and so it can be big contributors to iodide reduction. Yes.
So excess cruciferous vegetables which typically you're taking when you have cancer.
You try to eat a lot of green leafy vegetables and such it can reduce thyroid function.
I don't think to the point of this person's blood levels so I don't think that is our culprit if this person listens to this video I don't think that's our culprit.
The person could have mild hypo thyroid functionally because of eating a lot of cruciferous vegetables but nothing in the range that we were talking about.
Should I reduce this type of vegetables no one would.
And black sand be used I think they've had topically to treat cancer.
A breast cancer mask that is large but close to the surface well that depends on who you ask.
It depends on really how close to the surface it has to be pretty close to the surface to draw the breast cancer.
But here's the here's the upside on that if you put black sand on your breasts and you have a fairly large mass let's say several millimeters underneath the surface.
If it can't draw it out it's not going to do any damage to the breast tissue itself where you put the black sand.
So the nice thing about black sand is that it won't do any damage to healthy tissue.
It will only gobble up cancer cells so but before you do that we need to have a discussion because there's a whole lot more to this.
If you put black sand on the breast cancer then just give it a shot because if it does work it will open up and open wood and start drawing the cancer out and now you are fully committed because you may put that black sand on there 25 times and continue to draw cancer cells out so you have to know what you're getting into before you do that.
So black sand and our store for people especially down patients just to give them a goal.
Make sure we have a conversation before you.
A couple of questions here when using my original right protocol I used to regulate to get I used to get regularly used to regularly get red patches over the tumor areas and off of the tumors themselves with fish.
I consider this good immune response since receiving my updated right program I experience less on this and now I do not think I have that this response yet with the latest updates that went out to everyone.
I know the person who asked this question and in testing today you just got an update sent out to you know to be right so watch for that.
Yes, that can be a good thing it can change when your body changes especially if you're doing some people therapy or something like that there could be major changes on how your cancer response as well so is there any harm going back to the old right program well.
The only problem with the old right program that you had is it is what's called a version five program of the duty cycles are incorrect.
So you could be below you could blow fuses and you could blow transistor other than that the frequencies are fine and you certainly can.
So just watch that you're not blowing fuses or blowing the transistor on the back.
Certainly absolutely do not run the old high and probably programs make sure you're ready to do I would like to test to see if there's a programming so I didn't send you up we did that.
I said the chief swap update in last week should I expect to do yep so that's already what out today.
So good. This person has a home key M F unit most of our patients do not have a home key M F unit.
Say I received the travel case unit and with it came a mat.
So you can plug different apparatuses into it so that you're receiving the pulse to electromagnetic frequencies either through a mat which gives you a real broad.
Contact area which is nice for just general health that's nice for just to help you feel better to just add cell charge to a larger area the mat is really nice.
And then it has a large ring and then a double ring taped together the double radius called the butterfly ring yes.
And that can be used over a person's head if they have brain fog that can be you know you could put the rings around your breasts like this person's going to talk about the second you can put it around your elbow your knee.
So the butterfly ring is maybe one of the more useful pieces.
Use it like a clamshell and you open up the clamshell and you can put it right over your breast and you can put one side of that clamshell down at your lip belt and the other side can go way up over your whole breast.
Personally, if I had breast cancer that's what I would do and I would use that.
That's your how to use it as best as able or around and over my armpit yeah I think you're describing the same way I just said gets to live tumors then as well yes.
But I cannot get it over the breast tumors in this way.
Oh yeah, maybe that's an issue. So maybe you want to just do the clam like this and get those little areas that switch to the ring and then the ring it's larger so you know oh my gosh, it's way too big.
You need just one edge of the ring on where you're trying to treat so just understand that it's not.
You have to have the whole ring treaty you could literally put it on edge and put it on your body, you're just getting that electrical frequency.
I can get to I can get it close so I can feel the pulsating in the breast tissue but not in the tumor area typically won't feel the pulsating as much in the tumor because it's a dancer.
So you're going to feel it in the last dense areas, the only alternative way is to lay the big ring over the breast tumor area then the ring is so large it goes way over my ambulance yes then maybe put like a pillow underneath your abdomen so you're getting more the frequencies back at your breasts.
It is hard. I wish they had you know multiple other rings and stuff to use they just don't so kind of got to get creative.
If the machine cord attachment for the larger ring seems loose.
It does not go into the port area stuggling is the other attachments as long as it's working that's all that matters.
If you think it's defective will certainly give you the name of the rap and you can contact them I can contact them for you as well.
But as long as it's working if it's like really oddly loose like this is not really this doesn't look right at all when we should all pass came about that at least he might say no that's normal he might say no that's not I don't want to send you another ring.
So we'll ask about that.
So do the only questions that you sent me so do you guys want to chat in some questions here we go.
I'd like to run a true right gallstones program that says to use it with the qx tumble okay so whatever you look at any of the other programs you're using and it says oh use it with this bulb or this bulb don't just you could just ignore that and use it with the hammer bulb but
it's kind of partly to sell more so
just use it with the hammer bulb if you can save benefits.
Sorry I've asked this before but I'm getting conflicting answers today versus a week or two ago what I asked this H bot should this be only outside of the 40.
Okay so the conflict in the answers is because we're kind of just making an educated guess I haven't seen any data that H bot is bad for you know wall you're you know in that 48 hour window of people but if we want to make sure we're keeping your oncologist happy it might be good to wait that 48 hours.
So yes I talked to your other doctor today and that's what I mentioned that it might be good to wait and do it outside of the 48 hour window just so we don't you know conflict with you know the benefits of chemotherapy you know if you're choosing to do chemotherapy we want the chemotherapy to work so I don't want to do anything that's going to conflict with that.
Can you clarify pf over head can help with brain fog yes but you just got to turn it up really slow so you can actually get really bad headache.
If you don't do that and I can speak from experience so go really slow with that pf over the head can be beneficial don't try to muscle it out you're going to do it really hard so I get better you'll end up causing more inflammation.
So it's it's just be careful with that but it can be super helpful.
Let's stick this of the blacks have application affect the penetration depth no not really you just need it to cover the area you go any thicker it's just going to dry out and be wasted.
No, if testing found that dairy should not be eaten does that eat that eating the bud with cottage cheese should be stocked well.
I know that Budweaks says that when you put the oil in the cottage cheese it changes the fat in the cottage cheese.
Maybe it does change the fact that the cottage cheese I don't know I've never seen a study that showed that but certainly it doesn't change the fact that the cottage cheese still has a lot of growth hormones and such so I that is that is a that is a touchy subject because sometimes Budweak can be doing the Budweak can be really helpful if that's your only dairy that you're eating.
And you feel like you're being helped by the Budweak that I'd say stay with it if you are cheating butter and things like that that I'd say you got to rethink that so that's hard.
All said so four table spoons of cottage cheese and okay to continue benefiting from the increased the mega trees yeah so if you feel like you're benefited from but we've always let people do the Budweak.
Even if their cancer is a driver as long as they felt that that was a big help I'd like to get an infrared heat pad to put over my gallbladder and liver are there any brands you recommend.
Yes we have one online it is on our site it's called up real quick so what I use we use we get gifted them to all our kids for Christmas.
It is the their as such so the their as such eating pad that's the brand and it's got the crystals on it and it's an infrared heat pad very good company very good quality that's what I use that's what I suggest their as such.
We just search infrared heat pad just on our site you'll see the their as such.
My wife has neuropathy after having four months of cable we have been using the rebuilder for the last four weeks and receiving some positive results however is there anything else we can do with repairing the nerve damage.
So the rebuilder is a little FDA approved device for neuropathy that works really well but it does take a lot of time.
It's stimulating the nerves at their frequency to help regrow nerves.
It takes time so you're just going to have to keep it up also make sure you're doing the iron pro wave the detox setting that will help a lot to because this is a chemically induced neuropathy so the more of that chemistry you can get out of the body the better off you're going to be.
What is a P E M F machine a P E M F machine is an electrical pulsating machine that can be really good just to help with cell charge.
Just help with immune function.
I wouldn't call it a cancer killing device at all it's not something that we know really push for our patients but it could be very helpful for a lot of people it's really it's a device that can actually be very helpful for literally everybody.
But it's not necessary for everybody but what does test positive we do mention and talk about it but you do want to it's something you want to look into the problem is they're not cheap.
So a good P E M F machine is going to run you about $10,000.
I don't remember I think ours is like 800 or something like that so they're not inexpensive and but it's good to have.
Thank you for talking about Budwig instead of eating the mixture might it be beneficial just to take the flax seed alone.
No it's totally different you'd really need if you're going to do Budwig you have to do it right and you have to do the con's shoes.
Is it okay to continue taking supplements taking vitamins like vitamin D and healthy might have multivitamin if they're not on the supplement protocol the DS the ES.
So make sure you're taking a let me type this out.
So make sure you're taking when you talk about your supplements I do have a video on this but your vitamin E so vitamin E has four inner particles and four outer shells.
So a lot of the vitamin E that you buy at the store is going to be alpha to cough for all or alpha beta to cough for all or alpha gamma to cough for all.
So the outer shells of the vitamin E are called to cough for us and they are good for different things.
And understand when vitamin E would all these supplements were discovered they were discovered.
Depending upon the microscopy they had at the time so all they saw was the outer shell and that was called vitamin E.
Well that is the first outer shell that's called alpha to cough for all so there's four outer shells alpha beta gamma delta to cough for all.
Well then later as the microscopy has improved they found those other outer shells and then they also found that it's actually has four inner shells.
The four inner shells are called the toco tree dolls.
The toco tree in all are the really the component of vitamin E that is most important for your heart most important for your vessels.
The delta toco tree at all is the most important for your blood vessels. It is also the most important for your for cancer.
So a lot of times when you go to the store and you buy vitamin E you're really getting alpha to cough for all or yeah alpha to cough for all which is just the outer the first outer shell which is really pretty worthless.
So you want to get a vitamin E that doesn't just say alpha or alpha delta or mix to cough for all you want one that has the toco tree at all as well.
The most important is the delta toco tree at all.
That's why we use the a pop E we private labeled the a pop E because it has that full spectrum of the toco for all and the toco tree dolls mostly to cough for us.
So that's really important.
The same thing goes through true for multivitamins.
A lot of the multivitamins out there have synthetic products in there. That's why we would rather have you just do greens instead of a multivitamins and also most multivitamins have a lot of methyl groups.
So cobalamine and methyl tetrahydrofolate can function to turn off gene so we don't want excess methyl groups with a cancer patient.
So I'd rather have you just do the greens product instead of a multivitamins.
Why is he okay on my protocol but dairy fed on my tumor because he doesn't have the same products as just regular dairy.
It is still dairy but it's refined and I've never made the but you know people patients have made the and it doesn't have the exact same products as dairy so somebody's like I really want to have something different on my toes that you know the key can be an option.
If you're going on a trip and you want to bring your right machine is it okay to put it through the X-ray machine at the airport.
Yes, it is. That won't harm it. I've done it dozens of times.
Could acupuncture help with their opathy possibly. Yeah, it's worth it. Give it a try. Yeah, there's some acupuncture or shelter that are real good that might be able to help with their opathy as well.
Another thing that can help with their opathy is vitamin B6.
So B6 is often used for their opathy that can be also a help.
So consider that my old drive protocol I am pro wave had a detox program. I do not see the detox plan pro in the new material set and uploaded.
I do the old I am pro wave detox program and felt so good you can try it just be careful you're not blowing users.
Also you can go into your right settings into the alphabetical list in the folders you can scroll down to see the I am pro wave folder and it's probably in there.
You spell that for vitamin E. So the cough are all right there with a total tree at all.
The paper.
Oh, thank you.
Any other questions. All right. Well, I think I will side off for today.
A little under the weather today is yesterday and it's time to chill and today it's a scholar. So I apologize for that.
For questions if that could not.
So if you need more details on any of that, make sure you let us know.
All right, hopefully this recorded and we'll get it up on the site. Hopefully everybody's in the membership site. I know everybody's asking questions and the sides of that's good.
All right, everybody, you blessed and we'll see you next week.
Oh, how do you join the membership site.
You should have gotten an email.
For that, make sure you just email the info at cuttersfootic.com if you have not gotten an email, you can't find it.
Search the event you can search your email, your main email for info and cutters for the core for membership and you should see an invite.